alors on a ce soir à l'occasion de son
anniversaire et je crois même que jean
paul nous regarde
voilà je vous le dis donc ça c'est un
honneur absolue voilà donc j'ai faim
j'ai fait un énorme bisou à jean paul on
voulait faire un top 5
voilà des films de bébelles enfin des
scènes de bébelles en numéro 5
on a mis l'interrogatoire dans le
marginal c'était un film de 83 dans
lequel jean paul belmondo juin
commissaire de police
vous allez voir qui sait y faire en
terme et en matière d'interrogatoire
jean-paul qu'on aime se faire on se fait
que cinq extraits de jean paul à on
avait envie de se faire un clip
aujourd'hui et voilà même vous avez
envie de vous faire qu'il faut regarder
numéro 5
alors nous adresse profession sa cause
morny nom adresse profession si tu
réponds pas ceux des centres où stocker
48 heures alors voilà dernière fois nom
adresse profession n'obtiendra rien
comme ça sinon c'est pas le bon système
back une conne pareil auprès d'autres
systèmes
mais si je vais t'expliquer tétouan
moore août était hier soir sur la pâte
est malade toi tu sais plus edwy bon on
va reprendre calmement
sinon où tu étais hier soir ça c'est vu
on discute on voit ce que je t'ai dis tu
frappes le type est pas content il va
plus parler tu reconnais
reblocage voilà faire perdre
on a bien tout ce qu'on veut si on a la
manière tout est dans la manière
livia dolo l'esma les a montées blanco
10 rue saint-jacques prostituées bah
voilà jean paul belmondo exceptionnels
cession anniversaire aujourd'hui
mais la casse pour moi pour moi jean
paul belmondo franchement c'est le plus
beau gosse je vous jure que c'est vrai
et bon mot voilà y'a pas c'est ici c'est
voilà c'est mon idéal
voilà sofina il est exceptionnel et puis
surtout la façon de distribuer les
gifles moi ça m'a toujours fait marrer
yann lui l2 il ya deux gros metter de
gifles en france il ya lui et ya lino
ventura qui est exceptionnel et gérard
depardieu aussi dans beaucoup de ses
films
vous parlez de gilles c'est vrai qu'il a
mis pas mal de tanis dans ses films
c'est un patron de la bagarre ya rien à
dire alors c'est vrai que c'est un
ancien boxeur
voilà jean paul regardez comme il est
beau regardez moi cette merveille là on
a voulu faire une petite compil de ses
meilleures scènes de bagarres regarder
[Musique]
je voulais pas la gifle et je te jure
c'est rosen qui me l'a demandé
[Musique]
moi non plus je n'ai pas de gifler
rester dans le professionnel je me
rappelle qu est ce qu on fait farges on
fait quoi par jean mathieu tu veux dire
un truc sur jean-paul je ne peux pas te
dire en plus et en dehors de ça c'est
une émotion il ya quelques années dit en
train de déjeuner que chargé rares
restaurants
je suis allé le voir j'étais tellement
gêné de le déranger un amour toujours
gentil moi j'ai une affection pour lui
comme toi je connais tous ces films
parker c'est le plus grand et cc c'est
vraiment c'est quelqu'un que j'aime
d'une mais d'une affection sans nom je
connais tous et tim parker pour voir une
petite imitation
que faisiez-vous dans la nuit du 12 au
13 e et le hainaut fait bien avec le il
m'a fait bien bravo monsieur ça si
jean-paul nous regarde je pense que ça
ça a dû le faire plaisir castelli nom et
moi c'est vrai que que la pelouse de
hull et une qualité qu'on trouve
vraiment chez les restes à il est
exactement même dans la vie dans ses
films il s'intéresse à vous il vous dit
bonjour monsieur
mais de quoi dans la vie c'est un c'est
vraiment un mec est incroyable et moi
pour mes dix ans on peut en effet une
surprise j'ai fait mes dix ans avec lui
dans un restaurant il était venu il
s'était assis à la table et c'était pour
moi comme si je voyais le messie
franchement c'est un mec en or vraiment
c'est un jeune et c est joli mois la
première fois que j'ai vu jean paul et
et qui m'a et qui savaient qui j'étais
je vous jure c'est vrai il ya pour moi
c'était le rêve de ma vie j'ai appelé
tout le monde après gély jean paul
belmondo sais qui je suis et mozyr
c'était pour moi la la la la
consécration c'est que ces essais et
wallace et je suis poli je suis vraiment
fou de ce mets que oui j'ai khalid
voulait dire un truc on a et malgré les
années malgré les générations nous on
regarde tous ses films encore une fois
avec les enfants le secondaire
ça ne veut absolument pas et oui la
castagne oui les gros bras oui la boxe
mais y'a un truc chez belmondo c'est
qu'il est doué pour la vie il aiderait
pour l'amour moi j'avais envie d'être à
la fois sa femme sa fille et sa mère sa
soeur en fait et en fédérateur
voilà c'est un héros un héros ordinaire
et extraordinaire et c'est son
anniversaire aujourd'hui vous souhaite
un bon anniversaire on voulait montrer
voulait se faire dès klifa on a choisi
aussi
une scène du film le magnifique car une
chose est sûre c'est que jean paul est
magnifique c'est un beau gosse et même
là j'ai encore vu des photos lui et les
magnifiques qui plaisait à beaucoup de
femmes la preuve avec cette mythique
scène de la piscine regardez jean paul
belmondo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pur plaisir aux femmes je ne sais pas
quelle quelle souris contexte o'leary
gilles verdez voulait dire un truc une
bonne année derrière jean-paul on vous
rappelle cette dernière de jean paul
belmondo oui ah ouais vraiment bon
anniversaire alors au delà de l'acteur
c'est un personnage que tous les
français adorent il ya souvent des
acteurs ou des gens qui sont connus qui
peuvent être clivant je lève je n'aime
pas vous ne trouverez jamais personne
qui n'aime pas jean paul belmondo parce
qu'il est resté proche accessible
sympathique ouvert et ça c'est
formidable moi c'est ce que je préfère
rené tu veux dire un truc toiture est
sûre jean paul lay et à marseille il
avait tourné borsalino avec un qui
allait de l'homme et dernier rama il est
venu à marseille là parce que le château
de la buzine il avait une exposition sur
lui ouais mais bon le truc que je
m'entraîne le plus de bernaudeau ses
lobes d'oreilles autres sur toile harper
et délits
il reprend le frais poêlé au régime al
son collègue lui dit si tu vois la
manade les aventures f ordinaire l'ordre
de rue rouge à média tu es tu nous a
fait rêver en en faisant la série le
voilà on était dedans je vous remercie
jeff également des fonctions sont voilà
notre pote allons parler moi qui doit
être acquis avec lui d'ailleurs jeff qui
que j'embrasse très très fort jeff qui
organise toutes les expos sur jean-paul
qui fait des choses incroyables
jeff cathy je fais un énorme bisou on va
faire une petite compil cascades et
après on a on écoutera mathieu dernier
petit truc il compile des meilleures
cascades de jean-pierre il faut savoir
que c'est lui qui faisait les plus
grosses cas ce qu'assure moi je vous dis
à chaque fois que je les revois je les
aime tellement j'ai peur pour lui je me
dis même maintenant je sais qu'il va y
arriver mais j'ai peur quand même
regarder
on va leur dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais les cascades de jean-pierre même
maintenant je les revois je vous dit
j'ai peur et bras voire rémy julienne
aussi voilà le grand cascadeur qui l'a
guidé sur toutes les scènes et ils nous
disaient voilà que jean paul était
exceptionnel j'avais reçu dans une
émission jean paul bonne anniversaire
accueil pareil castaldi paraît que tu as
été le casting on a vu le petit rafidain
voilà on est dans le bazar k way et
c'est vrai que j'ai fait le casting pour
jouer le petit garçon et c'est vrai que
c'était très très blond à l'époque quoi
il donne ça fait le casting pour l'as
des as they think pour l'os des hommes
d'un an le colosse des heures et en fait
quand je suis arrivé avec ma bouille
toute ronde et ma belle chevelure blonde
on va discuter franchement au jeu ce
rôle là ça va être un peu compliqué
parce que j'avais un poste d'arrière
qu'autre chose et mais j'aimerais passer
le casting à l'époque c'était margot cas
politique était la directrice de casque
d'une grande dame personne ne connaît
mais voilà je vous le dis quand même et
j'ai été pris mais s'il vient d info
merci bribes d'infos mon pote mathieu
madame et genre il était trop beau pour
le casting
non ce que je voulais dire aussi qu'elle
sait que ces troubles ont bon le site
beaucoup la désastre marginal fickou
voyous de magnifiques jeux les gros bras
mais faut pas oublier que cet acteur qui
sait tout faire
à bout de souffle de godard la sphère
stabilitrak tout c'est une menace c'est
des films géniaux à itinéraire d'un
enfant gâté
donc c'est en ça que mon petit coup de
coeur j'adore de l'ong effet du dos un
sac pour moi c'est le meilleur il peut
tout faire et toujours juste bonne
anniversaire jean paul je vous aime d'un
amour mais incommensurable moi aussi
alors est je voudrais qu'on se refasse
une dernière scène
voilà j'ai voulu mettre la scène finale
du film le professionnel or si vous je
ne sais pas si vous avez vu ce film
ou pas le professionnel c'est un mois
c'est un de mes films préférés de jean
paulin et à chaque fois on veut pas que
jean paul belmondo meurt à la fin des
films et donc sont là et bains jean paul
belmondo malheureusement il va mourir
alors c'est ma scène préférée parce que
c'est une scène où il se dirige vers un
hélicoptère et on vit ici il arrive à
l'hélicoptère et qui prends
l'hélicoptère il est sauvé et à chaque
fois on peut le revoir dix fois on est
persuadé qu'il va réussir à rentrer dans
l'hélicoptère
et à chaque fois on est déçu regardez
avec 7
oui bien sûr alors qu'est ce que je fais
colonel faites ce que vous pourriez
nécessaire je ne crois plus rien
monsieur le buste expédie les affaires
courantes
ma démission sera sur votre bureau avant
de twitter
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait monsieur le
ministre mais qu'est ce qu'il y avait eh
bien le tuer ou le laisser partir mais
c'est vous qui décidez il faut
c'est un ordre
jude au nord de tokyo
mais ce pays est chargé
ah ça nous fait mal encore un de revoir
ça ça fait mal alors la scène elle a
bien failli ne jamais être gardé car tu
es donc belmondo car tu es jean paul
c'est vrai que c'était trop risqué
financièrement pour les producteurs de
films à l'époque il était invincible
bien sûr dans tous ses films jean-paul
il avait tourné deux scènes
c'est louis l'épargné est celle où il
est tué et c'est la seconde qui sera
finalement regarder et c'est vrai
qu'elle est devenue culte
peut-être qu'elle aurait été moins culte
s'il avait été sauvée voilà mais c'est
vrai que c'est une scène qui nous fait
toujours ballon